my goals were to broaden my thinking  to become more of an international  researcher  and more of a cross-disciplinary thinker  and also to raise my profile within the  community  so that i can start having conversations  that take me to challenging places  that you know push me and uh  kind of move me to new directions and i  think that this  unique set of individuals and the  support that you receive from the  program  is an ideal way to do that so if you're  looking to take your research  out of your department maybe out of your  faculty only  and really push yourself in ways that  you don't necessarily know which  directions they'll be in and that's the  kind of person i think that would  really succeed as a c4s reality global  scholar  giving the opportunity to think in new  ways opens up pathways both in your own  brain but also just these connections  that you wouldn't have  naturally which is wonderful  [Music]